Hello,
hello, hello.
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome.
Howdy, howdy.
Bioshock!
Woohoo!
Bioshock.
Oh my gosh, wait, hold on.
I kissed my cat earlier.
And I've had a hair stuck on my lip.
I can't get it.
I think I got it.
I think I have it.
Wait.
I got it.
Nah, it's definitely my cat, sir.
It's black.
Thank you, guys, for coming in.
Thanks for waiting.
Also, um, Bioshock!
First time I've ever played.
Hello, Minto, and I was like you.
Oh, gosh.
I can't read.
I can't scroll back up.
Spoiler, don't kiss your cat after using lip balm.
Or if you are covered in ectoplasm.
Thanks for always lifting my spirits.
Thank you!
Sorry, it's one of those games where I'm locked in the
window.
Oh my gosh, I opened it.
Holy resolution Batman.
It was...
This is the... I'm playing the remastered version because I
was worried about resolution issues with the original.
And we're doing our best here.
It's seemingly okay right now.
Yeah, I'm locked in.
I'm locked in.
But, uh, yeah.
Original can be finicky.
That's, I've, I heard, you know, usually I like playing
originals of things, but, um, I often, you often find that,
uh, with, with age, they do not do well.
Crayon Bay!
Thank you so much for the best he gets it.
Thank you!
Timex, welcome back!
Oh, Tirt!
Tire- Tire- Tire- Ness.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Um, so sorry if I, if you super chat and I can't read it if
chat is going because, you know, I can only read so fast.
But thank you for the super chats.
Thank you.
Very much.
I have both.
So if we get into this version and it's kind of like, ugh,
things are not working out so well, we can just switch over.
It ain't no big deal.
It is Not a big deal No worries no worries But yeah This is
my first time playing Vioshock I know I know Big Daddy I
know Little Sister And that's literally all I know Can't
read, I'm too fast Fesna, thank you so much for the 10
gifted I can read a little bit A little bit I literally know
like nothing about this series so i'm very excited to go
through it with you guys first can't read this i can't read
this illiterate i can't read anything i can't read i can't
read Little Sister Minto Artist, please.
Yeah, I want to use Little Sister Minto Art for thumbnails.
So, yeah, I want to.
Museum.
Ring.
You know that nine out of ten ladies prefer the athletic
man?
Advertisement.
Sport to boost.
Oh.
Oh, that was a loading screen.
Welcome to the...
Maybe I should not be in here.
How do I get out?
Back to midvenue.
I wonder.
Should I play this game not controller?
But it's made for controller.
So I'm kind of like...
lots of spoilers we just nope out of there
controller's fine might be easier PC controls I always play
with my controller it's better in controller
but controller oh yeah with the FPS I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try Not controller.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna try.
I often don't.
But...
We could try.
We can see.
We'll see.
Window noises.
Oh, did you hear?
Sorry.
We'll see.
You know, I could always switch anyway.
So it's fine.
Okay.
game oh we'll do medium i've played other shooters i've
played doom every easy you're new to shooters medium you've
played other shooters hard you've played a lot of shooters
survivor every bullet counts i've played other shooters i
wouldn't say i've played a lot of shooters
i've played doom
Indeed.
Medium is premium.
You know, I didn't know that nine out of ten ladies
preferred the athletic man.
Now I know.
Oh my gosh, known for BS.
Thank you so much for the peak!
Thank you!
Oh.
Peak fiction.
I'm excited.
They told me.
Oh, there's no subtitles.
Son, you're special.
Me?
You were born to do great things.
Whoa.
Raiders.
Thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
They were right.
Jack with love.
Oh my gosh, Minto with love!
It's literally in two days.
I will turn on the subtitles once I am able?
I don't know if I am.
I don't want to accidentally skip a cutscene or anything.
Oh yeah, baby.
Is that my shoe?
Toes are out?
Never let go, Jack.
Whoa!
oh i can't all right one second let me options audio options
uh reverb
gameplay oh subtitles dialogue subtitles on a diff wait you
can change it oh whoa warning adjusting difficulty effects
achievements they're like Okay, okay.
Whoa!
I have two people, two people can fit on this, this, this
board.
Whoa!
You think they did this?
Why do we suddenly just crash?
Can I go back?
Are we the only one who survived?
Medium is premium.
Oh, I thought I heard someone behind me.
Why is it doing?
Oh, have I been pushing this thing this entire time?
I'm just like...
My plate, no!
Now I feel insecure without it.
Whoa, it's sinking.
It's making a whole lot of...
Oh, we're collecting junk.
It's making a... Why is it doing that?
Oh my gosh!
Titanic!
It won't let me go any further.
Wait.
I think I pushed my things to beyond where I can grab them.
No!
Oh, it's gone.
Oh my god, calm down, mister.
Why are you being so loud?
Very convenient.
We crashed right next to this light house.
Question mark?
It's cold, is it?
Are we really Titanic-ing?
Let's see.
It's so dramatic, I know.
Excuse me.
My toes are frozen.
Oh, oh, what does that say?
A quote from Andrew Ryan.
I hear like people talking or something in there.
Like a party.
Party, party.
propaganda no gods or kings only man is this our Andrew Ryan
oh here it is in what country is there a place for people
like me what's wrong with you are you an otaku too only made
only me no gods or kings only me
There's some fancy music going on.
Oh, I can jump.
We are on the sea!
Look at that fish!
No gods or kings, only fish.
I'm like seeing things.
I'm seeing science.
Hello?
This sub, it was made for me.
Why is it so smoky?
Industry.
What's the R?
Is that for Ryan?
What was it, Andrew Ryan?
Andrew Ryan?
How do you, does, how, do you, do anyone else here have two
first names as a first name and last name?
Which do you pick?
Art.
Oh.
Randro Ryan.
Yeah?
Only cool people had that.
Which did you pick?
the cooler one my mom has first two names or two first names
I do and I shared an office with a guy who also did what the
heck fancy venue for the jazz concert honestly this is such
a good vibe no man alright let's go in oh Bath is Sphere
lover.
Service radio.
I'm reading these from so far away.
Oh!
My last name is pretty lame.
Can I take yours?
What are you talking about?
Ten phantoms.
Eighteen phantoms.
Oh.
Ryan Industries, incinerate fire at your fingertips.
I am Andrew Ryan, and I'm here to ask you a question.
Sounds like Stewie family guys.
Is a man not entitled to the sweat of his brow?
No, says the man in Washington, it belongs to the poor.
No, says the man in the Vatican, it belongs to God.
No, says the man in Moscow, it belongs to everyone.
Instead, I chose something different.
I chose the impossible.
I chose rapture.
Crabs!
Whoa!
A city where the artist would not be in sense, where the
scientist would not be bound by Penny Morales.
This is all below me where I crashed?
Where the great would not be constrained by the small.
And with the sweat from your brow, Whoa.
Rapture can become your city as well.
Whoa.
Rapture.
Oh, who's that?
I think he's trying to get my attention.
Oh no, he's fixing something.
Whale!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All good things of this earth flow.
into the city because like the sewage and stuffer this is so
immersive this is so awesome welcome to rapture use right
click to toggle between weapons and plasmids okay do not
turn off the computer okay
it's me i'm i'm say i'm i'm i'm I'm not even a bother to you
guys.
I think I crashed and now I'm scared.
And my toes are really cold.
Oh, Johnny!
Oh, what a welcome.
Splicer female.
Oh, it's a good thing this door hasn't opened.
Oh!
No.
Oh, I think we're in trouble.
Radio?
I think we're in trouble, everybody.
Warning, flashing lights.
Oh, I have a health bar.
Oh, God.
Atlas.
Any ground would be Nice.
Bad this way.
Um, what about the lady that, like, has claws for hands?
Or claws for hands?
We're gonna need to draw her out of hiding.
Okay.
Vita chamber.
What's this?
If you are killed by the hostile denizens of Rapture, oh,
you will be revived live and whole at the last Vita chamber
you passed.
Some of your health will be restored and you will always
have at least a small amount of Eve.
I don't know what Eve is yet.
Veda chambers work automatically.
There's no need to use or activate them.
Oh yeah, that's handy.
Oh.
A respawn point.
So, our lovely city is gone to heck.
Oh man, just to be a fish in these kinds of situations seems
so...
Rapture is dead.
What happened here?
We're not your property.
Let...
I
need a weapon.
I'm so scared.
Ryan doesn't own us.
Screw Ryan.
I don't know that guy.
Let it end.
Let us ascend.
And then there's like business cards or something.
Attention, all bathysphere travel is now denied!
Rapture is dead.
Obscured.
Can't see anything.
Wait!
I can't see anything.
Holy cow.
Just a bit further.
How do you like that, sister?
Welcome to Rapture!
Oh yeah, fighting drone.
A crowbar.
Like this?
A wrench?
Oh yeah.
Oh, oops.
Yeah, baby.
Where am I supposed to even go?
What is that?
Rapture, Transit, Authority Station?
Cool.
Um...
Oh.
Is it coming at me?
Or...
Very slowly.
It's coming at me very slowly.
Ayya!
Are you evil or...
Oh!
Are you okay?
I got him.
Yeah, it was self-defense.
You got first aid when hurt, press F to heal.
Whoa.
How does this survive?
How does all this wood like last under all this pressure in
the water, right?
F and D.
chat.
Yeah, FN chat.
Potato chips.
Can I like, not take them?
Or can I not eat them?
Can I like just hold on to them?
I guess not.
One man's vision.
Mankind's salvation.
It auto-eats.
Dang.
Okay.
I'll have to save stuff then.
Wow!
I can't get over.
It's so cool.
Plasmids.
Okay, I'm gonna get superpowers.
Or something.
Pick your plasmids and evolve.
He is hungry.
He's too hungry, right?
Sorry, I'm like looking around because it's so cool looking.
Gatherers, garden.
Oh!
Power up.
Ugh.
Ugh!
What are these tattoos?
We got like chains on our wrists.
I'm okay.
I'm taking this really well.
Oh,
they're talking, but I don't hear anything.
This little fish looks like he just had his cherry popped.
Wonder if he still got some Adam on him.
Adam.
The audio is like delayed.
Either.
Let's bug.
Weak.
You're a weak chopper.
And is there a fish I will have towing it without Big Daddy?
Big Daddy!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
You'll be no better off with Metal Daddy, little fish.
See you floating on my...
Wait, Big Daddy's a bad guy!
I thought I was gonna be Big Daddy!
Wait!
I wanted to be Big Daddy!
Oh!
Little sister!
Look, Mr. Bubbles.
It's an angel.
I can see light coming from his belly.
Wait a minute.
He's still breathing.
It's alright.
I know he'll be an angel soon.
Oh, creepy.
Whoa!
Have a baby, Henry.
First time, Plasma is a real kick from a mule.
But there's nothing like a fistful lightning now, is there?
What if I just open this door?
Door control.
So I can electric bolt now?
Zap it.
Oh, I really can!
Whoa!
Wait, was there anything else up here?
What about my wrench?
Oh!
Okay.
Very nice.
Is there anything else up here?
Can I get another...
This looks like...
Little sister, no?
Almost the same outfit and everything.
Trash can.
Oh!
Okay, so you do want to be... See?
Exploring pace.
Alright, cool.
Let's go through.
Wait!
in this?
Oh, N-N-N-Num-Numotube!
Nothing.
Oh,
that's no good.
Oh!
Oh, that's no good.
Uh...
Am I gonna get shocked or... Because it's, you know...
If I... If I use, um...
Electricity in the water?
Uh, this isn't good.
Oh, I pressed shift, and I don't think I was supposed to do
that.
Oh, oh, let's just keep going.
Oh, oh, that's no good.
And close.
All right, we should be safe now.
Oh, wait, this place is flooded too.
Oh, that's no good.
Was that me, or did someone do the...
Zap him and whack him.
Two punch.
Where are they?
Uh.
Zap them.
And whack them.
Where are they?
Wait, what was that?
Oh.
An Arcadia Merlot.
Health gained but lost E from drinking.
I can smoke cigarettes even!
I'm just going crazy.
Oh, my eyes.
Oh,
sorry.
You all, you...
All this guy asked was for me to leave him alone.
What's going on?
I'm trying to...
Oh, shoot.
I think we gotta go up.
I'm
not even...
getting time to explore these guys.
Man, I'm fired.
Hold on, let's go back to this guy.
I'm taking everything.
What is...
Oh, this is the chamber.
Okay, okay.
There's so much stuff.
Hello.
Let me explore...
Oh, no!
It didn't beat the... I thought I was searching.
I thought I was searching him.
Loot everything.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Yeah.
Where is this coming from?
Independence.
Where is it coming from?
Up there?
Oh, oh he opened the door.
Or something opened the door.
Maybe I didn't.
Maybe it's motion action.
Oh, yeah.
It's B.
So this seems the elevator works.
Or it doesn't.
Uh, pardon our dust.
Okay, let's go ahead.
Might not be a great idea using it, but here we go.
If you can reach them in Neptune's bounty, then maybe just
maybe.
There he is.
Yeah, what the hell is going?
What's happening to me?
see my wife and child again please
i didn't ask for this follow the compass arrow to your goal
oh i see it now oh i hear a lady why are you there to sing
this song oh it's gone and i'm glad i need to wait for and
none why aren't you here why is it today and not then when
you were warm and sweet so why can't mommy hold you to her
breast and feel your teeth alone no no no first aid kit
we'll take that oh but mom and mem so we so what what's his
name died okay all right let's go get this lady i guess
So, I'm guessing, like, if it's red like that, they're bad,
right?
Wait, I have that now, too, though!
Am I in trouble?
Revolve.
Can I switch?
Okay, good.
We can switch.
I'm, like, in my trusty...
now or my wrench right now though also i feel like i've seen
people wearing these before like the this specific mask
maybe it was from this game then okay sorry i'm still
looking around the atmosphere is so cool the great jane
le marquard de puki okay let's go
be what I'm thinking of, you're right.
Oh, it's a fence in here.
Oh, I do what I want.
Wow.
Happy New Year, 1959.
Oh, dancing downstairs.
Let's go, baby.
Do you like naturally regen the plasma or do you have to get
items for it?
Okay.
That's a whiskey.
Oh no!
Only items.
I think I was thinking of Donny Darko with these masks.
Oh, there's definitely...
Oh my gosh, this is a little spooky, no?
Oh, it's so spooky actually.
Money?
Cash money?
Oh.
Whoa, what's happening with my vision?
Did you guys see that?
Wait, why?
Agosta!
I can use the sink.
Making sure I'm not gonna get ambushed in there.
We'll have diarrhea.
Wait, what?
Hey, Brenda.
You care to tell me why you've had a hole in the red?
The eyes of Plymouth Rock coming out of your crapper going
on three weeks now.
I ain't saying I'm Shakespeare.
I'm trying to run a respectable theater.
I got work and food coming in for me.
Ah!
Shit!
Oh my god, you scared me.
You must have heard me use the bathroom!
Why don't they have the doors on them?
Oh, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, let's go get this guy first.
Did I just see a shadow go by?
Am I crazy?
Horror games that are not horror games, my favorite genre.
No, right.
Yo, open up.
Don't be dramatic.
Oh, Charlie, where are you going?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, she's strong.
Bed?
Bed splice.
Wait, oh, there's so many places to explore.
Okay, hold on.
Music got a little funky.
Oh, where's our toads?
What was that?
Sometimes it's hard to like...
Oh, okay.
Vodka.
Oh my gosh.
Sometimes it's hard to see, like...
Or like you try to hover over something, isn't it?
Charlie!
I wish I could go any faster.
though.
I feel like I'm really slow.
If I press shift, it opens up that menu.
More money, baby.
Mr. Jai.
I just used one, but that's okay, actually.
Let's go, Diane.
Girl enraps her.
Silly enough to fall in love with Andrew Ryan.
Oh, I see control.
Yeah, okay.
It does make us faster, for sure.
Oops, I didn't mean to eat it.
Wait, I just realized.
But, Andrew Ryan had so many suitors.
Wait, I didn't...
Oh, I ate it.
I ate it.
Cigarettes.
Nico time.
Nico Nico time.
Health lost, but Eve gained.
Alright, so the alcohol...
Alcohol takes your...
I bet this probably all goes to the same place.
But alcohol takes your health...
No, takes your Eve, but gives you health, and then...
For
a minute.
Why?
Is that her?
Oh, what does she do?
What are you doing?
Little sister.
Somebody went and turned a sweet baby girl into
a wheel of rapture turning.
Everybody wants us.
Everybody needs us.
Am I gonna be okay?
Like, I now have this stuff in me too.
How much are you gonna stick that in there?
How much are you gonna poke him?
I want to jump down there so bad.
I'll be fine, probably.
You think so?
I want to see what happens.
Oh, wait.
I'm going down.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, maybe I'm scared now.
Maybe I'm scared.
No.
Oh!
I was gonna say you're gonna anger you're gonna anger him
I'm watching the show oh yeah yeah don't
notice me I'm just watching oh my god he's not coming this
way is he broken vending machine Where did she go?
Alright.
We're going where he went.
That's barely cool.
Oh, we can save our game.
So happy.
Let us new save you.
She went with daddy.
You can save any time.
Okay, awesome.
Oh, we're I'm totally just gonna follow him.
That's really good.
Ooh!
Gained health from cake.
Let's go in here.
Let's, um, anything in here?
You got anything?
You got some cash money, baby?
What about you?
Oh, yeah.
I keep giving me pistol?
Emo!
Oh!
Pew pew.
Is there like a way to block in this or not?
Oh!
I just got the pistol!
No.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
All right, yeah.
Six shots.
Shock an enemy in the water.
Oh, there were two of them.
See, that's what I was saying.
I don't think I should use the electric.
In the water, right?
Okay, I'm glad that my assumption seem to be correct.
Pick your plasma and evolve.
What's gonna happen to me?
Come bite the apple!
Ooh, la la.
Did I get this guy?
Oh, I think I did, yeah.
Double kill.
Some cash money.
Big daddy.
Oh, big daddy's got big money!
Okay.
What do you mean I'm easy?
Okay, I'm gonna pause.
Let's see.
Oh, that's an auto-save.
Alright, let's save.
Alright.
Booy!
Oh, I just saw it!
Oopsie.
Okay.
Um...
Good morning, Rapture!
Why would you name it this?
Why would you name your civilization rapture?
Then we have this area.
Oh, oh yeah, that's right.
I have to follow the arrow now, don't I?
Anyone in here?
Oh.
I can't carry any more first aid kits.
Okay, so I can only carry up to nine?
Isn't it from the Bible?
Yeah, but it's just like...
when everybody
goes to heaven?
Am I in the gents area now?
We shine shoes.
Wait, why are they connected?
I'm sorry.
Oh, the wall crumbled.
I suppose.
Yeah, everybody ascends.
Oh.
Ah!
Hello?
Oh, shoot.
Where'd the other person go?
I thought I saw one more.
Oh, you.
Yeah.
I got him while they were in the water.
Um, hello?
That doesn't sound good.
Jump on in.
The water's fine.
They're all jumping in.
Oh, Andrew Ryan is still alive.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
How do I redo this?
My vision.
How do I inject myself again?
R?
So tell me, friend, which one of the bitches It's automatic.
Okay.
I'll just wait then.
Here's the news.
Rapture isn't some sunken ship for you to plunder.
And And Lurion isn't a giddy socialite for me slapped around
by the government's model.
And with that, farewell or, thus Lovana and the Jedi.
Hmm?
I think your place is pretty...
...
Oh, shoot!
Uh-oh.
I think I'm in trouble.
Oh, you lose!
I didn't have to do anything.
Oh, there is a map.
Okay, awesome.
You get a hint.
Lucky.
Okay, so far, I don't know why this game is making me so
jumpy.
I guess it's because I'm, like, playing a type of game that
I'm not...
Quite used to, you know?
I don't play FPSs very often, so...
It's a bit spooky.
Yeah, it's pretty spooky now.
So if I... Oh, what the heck is that?
Oh, it's a vending machine!
Oh, okay.
Oh, whoa!
Oh, spoilers?
Spoilers?
Wait, wait, what is my active goal?
The past free will and free man.
I'm hearing somebody speak.
Oh, I could purchase stuff!
Oh!
Okay, for now we'll hold off.
Yeah, I'll hold off for now.
What?
Probably hearing people upstairs is probably what's going
on.
Diary.
It's right there!
Yes!
Oh, that's right.
He told me that once the scar tissue was gone, he was gonna
fix me right up.
Make me prettier than any girl I've ever seen.
Uh-huh.
Oh, it's Diane again!
Also, I just noticed our The compass is gone.
Beaten by a nose?
Steinman's?
Offers a comprehensive rhinoplasty service.
I love robbing the dead.
Alright, let's go.
Or...
not.
Never mind.
Oh.
Use that up.
Do you?
Okay, hold on.
Oh, no.
Wait, I was looking at the map.
Okay, okay.
So it's a puzzle of some sort.
You are so noisy up there.
Do I like...
Do I...
Uh-huh.
Let me see.
Well, these are moving.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe I...
Oh, oh, oh, I'm hacking.
Wait, I'm searching.
I'm looting and then I'm hacking.
Wait.
Hacked security bots are friendly and will attack your
enemies.
Why are you live again already?
Do you know what sleep is?
What are you talking about?
I was live so long ago.
Okay, what are we doing?
Oh.
Reveal tiles.
find pipe segments by revealing hidden tiles, swap pipes,
pick up pipes and swap them with another pipe to create a
connected line, make a chain to the exit pipe.
Guide the flow of the metallic liquid.
Looks like an ectoplasm.
Oh, so this is the exit here.
Okay.
Can I just unveil any one that I want?
You have limited time?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
We can make this work.
Okay, we'll just make it a long roundabout way of going, you
know?
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Wait, oh, shoot.
Wait, don't make it so high.
There, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And, uh...
Easy!
It started moving, so I got freaked out.
Wait, if I click finished?
Oh, yippee!
Okay.
If it works, it works, right?
I performed at least one successful hack.
Hack successful!
Hack the security bots are friendly and I'm gonna attack
your enemies.
Are you gonna follow me or?
Sounds like a really annoying fly.
Holy!
Oh my goodness.
Maybe I need to switch to my gun too.
Where'd he go?
Oh, six shots.
Oh, he's got coffee.
I'll drink that.
Okay, I gotta get used to using a gun in this game, huh?
I should probably use a gun in this game, huh?
Adams changes.
Yes.
We could lop a boil here and shave down a beak there, but
could we really change anything?
Adam gives us the mean things to do it.
And Ryan frees us from the phony ethics that held us back.
Change your look, change your sex, change your race.
It's yours to change.
Nobody else is.
I've got to become a cat.
So I don't have to do any work.
Can I change my species, please?
Change your diapers.
This guy is bumping into everything.
He's so clumsy.
Um, I imagine if I turn this on, I'm gonna get...
Bump.
I'm gonna get...
Axe is denied!
If you want to use him, here's the Axeman's key.
Where is he?
He's the one that runs this place.
Well, I don't mind this.
Oh, okay.
The doyman ain't that kind.
And frankly, human.
I don't think anybody is, huh?
Get the key from stymond.
Oh, is that a new gun?
Oh my god!
I didn't realize it still had my gun.
I thought I was on my...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, a machine gun!
Oh, let's go.
This is the lady I've been hearing.
Get her gun for more bullets.
Where?
Come in.
This guy?
What are you doing?
All right, that's open now.
Back on this thing is crazy.
Wait, wait, wait.
We have rules here.
What are you talking about?
Wait, oh my gosh.
I'm trying to- there we go.
Let's get out of here.
Holy shit!
Scared the hell out of me!
I
think I blew up my own droid.
Oh shoot.
Wait!
Oh!
Oh
my god, you're shooting at me too.
We're bonking?
Oh.
More gun.
Everybody's got cash money on them.
My drone!
I think I blew him up.
I think I ate it in him blowing up.
Is there any other buddy else?
My drone!
Plasmic ooze.
Before you know what you'll be as bright as rain.
Remember, a smart splicer is a happy splicer.
I wish that were me.
Yeah?
Gosh, I'm looting everything.
Oh, I miss him.
He was a little annoying, but I still miss him.
Hey, Jerome.
What the heck is this?
Alright.
Is this a door?
No.
Oh, it's a ghost.
Is this Diane?
Is that like the ghost of Diane?
Corpse.
Oh.
I don't even see him.
There's somebody speaking, but I can't hear.
I can't find them at all.
A brick of picnic lantern will make a day off.
You keep an ideal for Steinman.
The dark bastard set up shop in the surgery wing.
That's ghost, too.
Oh, my bad.
Above all, do no harm.
Above all, do no harm, Steinman.
As he writes in blood.
Right.
Oh.
No!
I didn't mean to... I meant to press T.
My hands are... My fingers are too small!
As your tools and
happy enough to take off a water tube or turn a real circus
freak into something you can show in the daylight.
No!
That was then.
It's hard to reach.
It was pretty well.
That's true.
Until
the job is done.
Right.
Alright.
Definitely hear people around here.
I wish I had my drone.
I'm gonna switch to my gun.
Wait.
What?
Who was shooting at?
Holy cow.
Who's shooting at me?
If I can even get there, to them oh my god it's a turret
yeah oh my god okay maybe if i try the other side holy cow
did i get it oh i did okay i can hack turrets too
something's the oh my god okay it'll revive okay i've
learned okay it's temporary I'm not reading chat very much
so sorry if you like try to tell me something and I just
don't see it that's that's yeah okay all right let's go hack
him let's go hack him hack okay start the hack what is that
oh oh my gosh all the way up here okay uh
do I have enough to like let's do this yeah Oh, whoops.
I should probably...
Oh, there we go.
Oh!
Oh no!
Um...
There we go.
Okay.
Yay!
We have the turret!
Foyled!
Oh!
And what is happening here?
Thank you, turret buddy.
Oh.
What is happening here?
It's very distracting.
I'll be honest.
Oh.
Was that him?
It's pretty distracting.
On the surface, the parasite expects the docks to heal them
for free.
The farmer to feed them out of charity.
How little they differ from the pervert who prowls the
streets looking for them.
for a victim he can ravish for his grotesque amusement.
It's
fine.
With Adam and my scalpel, I have been transformed.
But is there not so much pattern?
What if now it is not my skill that fails me?
But my imagination.
My imagination.
Not the funeral home.
Alright, let's look around a little bit more.
She's really making her way over there.
Did I loot this one?
Oh!
I got some smokes though.
That lowered my health a little bit but...
That's a-okay.
What else do we got here?
I saw something else.
Glimmering over here?
Oh.
Hack the turret to make it your ally.
Oh!
Nice dodge, thank you.
We're hacking?
Holy cow.
This is fun, though.
I like these.
Let's,
uh...
Yep.
That should be good, right?
Yippee!
Is this the remastered version?
It is.
It is the remastered version.
These get so annoying in late game.
Uh oh.
I like them for now though.
They're fun.
What was that armor piercing pistol round?
I hear some lady doing something.
I like that once you search something, it doesn't allow you
to search it again so you don't like...
You know what I mean?
So you don't waste your time.
Who's laughing?
This game is scary!
People are scary.
Okay, let's keep going.
I am supposed to go this way maybe?
What is this?
I can hack it.
More items available, all prices reduced.
Does this mean the difficulty?
Yes.
Do you guys think I can do it?
Buy out with $88.
Hack everything.
If I...
If a hack is not successful...
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Does it...
Oh, it's fast.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oops, I messed it up.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Okay, I, like, really got hurt from that.
Well, now I know.
It has been brought to my attention that some citizens have
discovered ways to hack the vending machine.
Circus of Valley.
You do not need to remind each and every citizen of Rapture
that free enterprise is the foundation upon which our
society has been established.
Parasites will be punished.
I don't know something about this guy that ain't all right.
This one's also hard.
I don't know.
Do it again?
I'm gonna die.
How much is it?
Welcome to the circus of value.
Save scum it!
Oh, can you?
Hack everything.
You can still buy from it if you fail.
Yeah, but it hurts me!
It's short circuit.
Save scum?
Okay.
New save.
We're safe scumming right now.
Alright, I believe in this one.
Oh, it's the same as before.
As soon as I get something that...
Here we go.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not good.
Uh, shoot.
You.
And then...
Oh my god, these are hard.
Wait, these are really hard.
These are really difficult.
Okay.
I saved this some time.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh, I
did it!
Yeah!
Woo!
The stress!
Holy cow.
Welcome to the search.
But we did it!
We did it.
Yeah, I didn't even need to save Scum.
We're too good.
We're too powerful.
Okay, I will get some first aid.
Actually, get some Eve.
Have a single armor piercing round.
They give you exactly six shots.
Oh, scary.
What's this?
Shotgun.
I like it.
Hacked!
Wait, so will this stay hacked?
Okay.
A gun with only one bullet.
I have 10 bullets.
Spoiler, yeah, get a shotgun.
It stays?
Oh, nice!
This one stays hacked forever.
I am gonna focus on now for health and stuff though.
I think we'll hold off for now on anything else.
Oh.
I'm gonna save again though because I...
Is this the one that...
Wait.
This is the one I just did, yeah.
You need more bullets.
I'll get them, I'll get them.
Ship to choose weapon...
Oh!
Does it pause the game when I do that?
What's up, my knee?
Oh, it's...
It does!
Oh wait, that's awesome!
For someone who panics like me, you know?
What's this?
I could heal!
Oh, wow, okay.
Is it one-time use?
Wait, I think I just saw the guy go up to the other side.
Oh, there he is.
Everything can be hacked.
Yeah, that's not my ass though.
Let's try it.
Let's hack it.
Oh!
It's not even that difficult.
Or so it says.
What's like the best strat for these guys?
Zigzag strat.
Is that what I just did?
Also now, heal is $10 instead.
Does it give me a health pack or does it heal heal me?
I don't want it to heal heal me.
I don't need it right now.
Eternal flame.
Damn, they dangerous.
Gabe's stressing me out.
Whoa.
Give me the shotgun, baby.
There's a lot of places to search, but I'm realizing that
supplies feels rather limited.
It heals, drops, and med pack if you break, but there's
no...
Okay, no more station.
Got it.
Steimann.
I know medical civilian is your matter.
But you might want to cogitate on this.
Ocean water is colder than a witch's tip.
You don't heat the pipes, the pipes freeze.
Pipes freeze, pipes burst, and then rapture leaks.
Now, I realize you're a posh sort of geyser, and frankly, I
don't give a toss if you piss or go fishing.
but once rapture starts leaking the old girl's never gonna
stop and then i'll be sure to tell ryan he's got you a thank
you yeah it seems like you know building a whole society in
the water is kind of difficult
hack only this machine must be hacked to access whoa Wait,
how difficult is it?
I like the hacking, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god, it's like so easy!
Or so it says.
Oh.
Easy.
Hack is fun.
I like the hacking.
It didn't make it any cheaper though.
Although this one was still 19, I guess because you have the
haka to get it.
Okay, anyway.
Um, there was more stuff up here.
Trying to explore.
A rapture reminder.
The bottom of the ocean is our home, but it can also be a
dangerous place.
Okay, we went this way.
Report any unexplained water prompted to the central
council.
Am I supposed to go in there?
Into Dr. Steinman's aesthetic ideals?
Well, hold on.
I'm still looking around.
Oh!
Yes!
Whoa!
Did he die?
Where is he?
Oh shoot.
I'm trying to...
There we go.
Where did he?
Oh shoot.
I'm trying to...
Where did he go?
I think you went through there.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, stop!
I should probably use a gun for that, but...
I killed him, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
You can just buy more things.
Why do you mean he used all his staking grenades?
In loving memory.
Oh, wait, this is not Andrew?
Oh, they look the same.
the time, you know?
Every guy had this haircut and this mustache.
This is Winston.
Yeah, it's the look of the era.
Everybody looks like Adam's family.
You know?
What's his name?
The husband.
It is a very dapper look.
It's very fun.
Whoa.
Surgery Picasso.
Goumet!
Yes, Gomez.
When Picasso became bored of painting people, he started
representing them as cubes and other abstract forms.
The world called him a genius.
I've spent my entire surgical career creating the same tired
shapes over and over again.
The upturned nose, the cleft chin, the ample bosom.
Whoa.
Steinman.
This is, like, more open world than I expected it to be.
Well, not open world, you know what I mean?
But, like, it's not, like, directing me to, like, one place.
Like, I am able to, kind of explore a little bit.
Yeah, a little less linear.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do I do about them?
Zap them?
Can I hack them?
I'm not a good hacker.
I'm hacking?
I'm not hacking.
I'm playing Metal Gear now.
That's so funny!
Nice!
Wait, do I have any more?
Oh, shoot.
I have a single rat.
Okay.
These are delicious.
Crouch.
Yeah, yeah.
I figured I needed to crouch to get in there.
Lots of stuff around here, though.
I'm still searching.
Ooh, first aid kit.
We'll take that for sure, for sure.
Oh, why do I feel like there's going to be somebody in one
of these?
Oh, what's that?
Oh, machine gun rounds.
Can I open these?
No.
I like hearing the water sounds.
Alright.
Why don't I get in the shotgun?
Q or B to change the ammo type.
Oh, thank you.
Also, I'll take that.
Oh, this is...
The parasite wanders the whole.
We rebuild our city in the dark and the dark.
Uh-oh, wait, are they coming?
Are they going to be...
Is this ambush or?
No?
Oh my gosh, she scared me.
Incinerate.
New plasmid.
Incineration.
When it absolutely positively has to erupt in flames, don't
wait.
Incinerate!
Whoa!
Set the objects and creatures on fire!
Repeated use To increase the pain.
Aegis, well, for that.
Fire spreads.
Oh, shoot.
My bad.
It sounded just like them.
Oh, good.
We can get out.
How do I switch?
Um.
Okay, like so.
Okay.
Is it the same?
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Very cool.
We'll switch right now to something that's a little less you
know.
I think C to crouch.
I don't know why, but it's like throwing me off so bad.
because I keep wanting to hit, like, control.
Well, that was fun.
We got them so easily.
Tasty potato chips.
Really, really old design.
No, that's okay.
I'm going to save real quick, by the way.
One thing that I did, if you guys don't mind sometimes
telling me to save, because one thing I did here is that if
the game...
is to make multiple new saves because the game
could crash.
So, we have to do be a little bit of a save goblin, yeah.
That's one thing I read when I was looking into I wasn't
wondering which one to play.
Oh, good.
We got to avoid the security camera.
Awesome.
But Yeah, I was wondering which one to play.
The original or the remaster.
Um.
I like how it's like, choose which plasma you want.
Thank you.
Alright, did we go?
I think my turret is going crazy, but...
Did it get him?
Or did it get got?
I can melt ice too!
With it?
Good job!
Who did you get?
No, wait, who did you get?
Huh?
Tell the minister, I'll just have to wait.
It's my daughter's wedding, not his.
Is this lady okay?
Or like, rather, was she...
I'm just gonna assume nobody is normal here, right?
Like everybody is kind of...
It's a lost cause for everyone.
Did I go in here?
Oh, that's right, I couldn't.
I don't think she's okay.
Oh, I was like, wow, what's that above me?
It's so far up in the water.
It's dirt on the ceiling.
Oh, look at the wheel.
Look how cute she is.
She's stomping along with him.
Big daddy.
so what were they built what what is his purpose you know
like just uh
are they going in circles or
i'm saving because i'm scared i'm saving because i'm scared
aesthetics are a moral imperative Steinman's aesthetic
ideals.
We're in the circle.
Why do you have two eyes?
Is there some law that says we must?
Two arms, two legs, two ears, two breasts.
I don't know.
I guess that's just how humans were made.
Holy cow!
You'll have to find some way to get through this, Georgie,
and Steinman.
Chin up now.
The Lord hates a quitter.
Oh wait, oh, oh I forgot.
You can hear that splicer sounding off.
Explosives are hard to come by down here.
Wait, oh, oh, oh, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, sorry.
Um, I can't move.
My computer is like, it's switched to Japanese and now it's
typing.
Wait, hold on.
There.
Oh.
Okay.
We should...
Nope.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I can't turn it off.
Wait.
Is this a bit?
Yeah?
No.
Okay, so the issue...
Let me explain the issue.
Because I know that Alt Shift works.
Okay, so first of all, my mouse cannot, like, leave the...
It's locked into the window, right?
It's locked in.
So that's the first issue.
I can't go up to the taskbar and like click the click the
click the to go back to normal.
But also, the second thing is if I alt.
Oh, wait, I think I got it.
Oh, oh, I was doing alt tab instead of alt shift.
Anyway, it was a fine telekinesis.
What am I doing?
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Telekinesis plasmids.
Oh, it's a thingy.
Anyway, um, we're fine now.
Sorry for the scare.
It scared me more than you, probably.
Wait, where am I supposed to go from here?
Actually.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Ah, another health station.
Okay, I'm going to try and hack this one.
Let's do it like that.
And then like that.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Like that.
There we go.
Oh, it's a good thing it wasn't a hardwood or else I would
have been dead already.
Oh, no.
You're throwing off my groove.
There we go.
Gotta find telekinesis.
So now it's cheaper to heal?
I'll let you look at that.
Free plasmids, a dandy dental!
Choose from slim down and telekinesis.
What if I choose slim down?
Oh my goodness.
I'm in my skinny...
Ballet a little light.
At surgical savings, we'll happily work out an Portable
payment plan for any major procedure.
Potentially terminal illnesses won't wait until payday.
Should you?
So I go through here?
No.
Still tell me.
I'm ready to burn.
That
thing uses a lot of power now, doesn't it?
There she goes.
Bye-bye.
I just used one, didn't I?
Dang it.
Someone be whistling.
Creepy.
Who's whistling?
Creepy!
One shot, Minto.
Yeah, baby.
Okay, I need to go probably through here.
They sound so close, you know?
Like when I hear them, they sound like right behind me.
So it's freaking me out.
Oh, I used the fire here.
Okay.
Ah!
You're on fire!
Okay, he's dead.
Help me find this patient.
That's kind of them.
They give that to you after you...
They force you to use your magic and then...
You're sorry.
You're plasmid.
That's a whole lot of bandages we just got.
Oh!
Shotgun.
Plasmids are magic.
Okay, I'm just going to keep calling it magic then.
I'm so sorry I'm going to save scum because I'm scared.
My magic.
Anyone want to mess with me?
Wait.
Oh, I got them all.
Nice.
There's a couple rooms here.
Where are we anyway?
Oh, this is the goal!
Gatherers garden.
what was that oh that was where i got the fire right so they
kind of force you to get the fire huh i don't know i don't
know where i am to be honest okay let's grab the shotgun oh
it's pretty oh shoot i knew this was gonna happen
i'm scared wait this is so scary Wait, this is actually...
Ah!
Oh,
I thought I heard one more.
Holy cow.
Gives me a shotgun, doesn't use it.
Just, you know.
Just Minto things.
That's so funny.
Oh, I'll eat that.
Ooh!
Okay.
Well, it would revive me and I wouldn't have to do this all
over again, so that's pretty nice.
Okay, um...
Give me the cash.
So I need to go to the dentistry.
Wait.
Oh, a health station!
We got this.
Uh...
I feel like I'm recovering.
dressing and how I do these.
Oh.
Oh, da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
da da da-da.
I'm still at work, but I hope the game is going strong.
I'm having fun.
I'm worried, though, because I fear, you know, when I pick
up the game again next week, I fear that I'm going to be
like, oh gosh, what are these controls again?
you know?
So I feel like this might be a...
Because I'm so not used to these kinds of games.
I feel like maybe...
I do this one a couple times a week.
Rather than once a week.
I need a minute to refresh for all the plasmids.
Yeah, I feel like it.
That's okay.
Okay.
Let's go explore.
over here first.
I kind of like this one because it shocks like it.
No, I can't hack it.
I can't hack it from here.
Maybe I can crouch.
Can it see me if I crouch?
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, I can, I can, I can.
Oh,
go!
Oh, go!
Oh, shoot.
I need a choppers key!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, my gosh.
Asshole.
Jump through the window.
Can I?
I mean, if I die, I regen right there.
Oh, gosh.
There's no way.
Hold on.
Let's let's let's let's let it die again and then I'll zap
it and then I'll I'll attempt to go through the window
Hey, okay, nope.
I don't think so
All right
Oh, I just realized I had like so much Is
that a turret right there
Yeah, someone's having a real good time over there, huh?
I can hack the safe.
What the hell is this?
Oh my god, wait.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, shoot.
No, dang it!
Let me try again.
Wait, this one's...
This one's so easy.
I didn't get a piece that I could use until...
Well, I guess...
Okay, I'm fine.
But, but, but, but.
You and then...
You?
Okay, we'll just have to like really, uh...
You know?
I need another Huang's boy.
There we go.
Ah, I did it!
Yahoo!
I like the music.
What is it?
I'm
scared.
Fantastic.
Oh, this is the telekinesis.
What's gonna happen to me?
I keep adding new plasmids, I'm gonna become as crazy as
these guys.
Oh, it's tennis!
Problem not with plasmid, problem with reaction time.
Oh, yeah, that's gonna be me.
You have run out of slots and have have to replace a
plasmid.
You can buy more slots at Gatherer's Garden.
Replace plasmids can be re-equipped at a gene bank.
No!
Wait.
Can I leave?
Oh, I can't.
Because there was a garden around here, I thought.
Oh, dang.
You're already a bit loony.
This poor dude, I, you know, at the moment, I don't know
anything, so I'm assuming that our plane crashed, and we did
not have any intention of being involved in all of this.
I wanted to keep all of mine that I have right now.
Right now, though, probably I feel like the electricity is
best because it also gets rid of machines so we'll keep the
electricity and we will um get rid of the fire and
catch grenades and throw them back that's not a grenade why
are people throwing grenades why are people throwing
grenades hold left okay hold left to grab release Release
left click to throw or press B to drop.
Hold left to catch grenades.
Oh.
Ooh, my vision gets really funky here though.
Oh my god, my vision though.
Okay, I'm seeing how...
Okay, I don't want to keep...
You know.
Electric fuck.
Throwing grenades is generally more healthy than holding on
to them.
I suppose that's correct.
I suppose that could be a good argument, right?
Oh, shoot.
Anyone else?
They all came out here.
Useless experience.
At the German prison camp, they put me to work on genetic
experiments on other prisoners.
They call me Das Wunderkind.
Das Wunderkind.
Germans.
All they can talk about is blue eyes and the shape of
forehead.
All I care about is, why is this one born strong and that
one weak?
This one's smart, that one's stupid.
All that killing.
You think the Germans could have been interested in
something useful?
Whoa.
Was the corpse always like this with the stuff stuck in it?
Like that, good, golly.
All right.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, nice.
I didn't notice that at all.
Oh, what's in here?
And
I telekinesis that?
I'm a little trapped though.
What is that?
Oops.
There's like a shadow of a corpse on the ceiling, it looks
like.
I think I got it.
Can't carry anymore.
Actually, uh...
There we go.
Money, money, money.
What's that?
Oh, nice.
Look at, we could search the turret even.
What?
I'm collecting bandages, but do...
Wait, are those used automatically?
I just realized, because I've been collecting them.
It says collected at least.
Oh, they're like food.
Okay, okay.
Good to know.
It doesn't say that I need to go this way, but...
Oh!
Wait, I'm trying to grab that.
Wait, actually, I can't.
Wait, oh, thank you.
Where am I?
Oh, wait.
in here sorry that the lights are kind of like crazy in this
sometimes there's so much to search oh i just clicked i just
did the bandages again wrench jockey combat tonics that's
what this is i thought it was going to be like a like a
permanent upgrade to my health or something
sorry jockey bulks up your upper body allowing you to wield
club-like weapons with unprecedented skill and power
compact tonics make you better at dealing and resisting
damage they're equipped separately from plasmas and other
types of tonics more wrench damage I'm a fan.
I'm a fan.
Now look at this.
I wasn't
sure if she was dying in the water or not, so I just took
care of it.
I wasn't sure if it was, you know.
Oh,
there's a security kit.
That's what that is.
Oh, that was a whiskey.
Oh, I don't think I should have wanted that, huh?
Okay, it does look this way.
Clinical trial, lot 44, Dr. Su Chong.
Client Fontaine Kitturistics.
Subject is white male, one Roland Wallace.
Can you hear me, Mr. Wallace?
Yes, sir, Mr. Su Chong, sir.
Very well.
Right, I'm introducing lot 44.
I wonder what's over here.
I'm just going to look.
What is that?
Oh, I hate the water effect.
It's so terrible.
Yeah, rip that guy.
Oh,
no!
This guy's tough.
I don't know if we can do it, guys.
It's already tougher.
Save scum?
You're right.
You're so right.
Pack up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, uh...
Oh, uh, it's not gonna work.
No, I'm already dead.
That was tough.
I don't even know if this is...
I don't even know if I have the skills to do this.
I don't have the brain capacity, I think.
I don't know if I...
How a practice run?
You got this?
No,
it's not giving me what I need!
Oh, I got it!
Oh my gosh, I got it!
I got it!
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Eve hypo.
All right, let's run.
hide from security camera you have hidden from security
camera okay I'm just hiding in here in case somebody runs
after me if they didn't want you saves coming the devs
wouldn't have implemented saving at save points only that's
so true I agree with that in fact I'm gonna save over that
too
save you can hack security cameras too oh you can okay good
to know
Well, I think we've done everything in here that we need to
anyway.
Today we came 32 years old!
JFC, happy birthday!
Thanks to your goofiness, cool tasting games, give me great
moments.
Last year was harsh on me, I'm finally better so much.
Oh, thanks so much for everything so far!
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, there is something shiny under there.
Wait.
I got it.
All right.
What
were you saying?
Okay, so this way is the death.
we still need the key um
michael this map i'm sorry it doesn't help me at all i get
so confused by it
wasn't i just in here i didn't see the gatherers garden
the map in this game sucks i can't follow it like at all so
okay i think this is like below floor right and then this is
the above floor so because we because i went downstairs
through the
ice yeah that's where you got telekinesis here oh what
didn't it say a gatherers garden i can purchase a new slot
with enough adam
Clear the debris for the enemy grenades.
Oh.
Okay.
This is where we were before.
I remember.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, this is where he blew it up and blew up his area.
Yes, yes, yes.
now okay
of Eve I've hacked yeah I did hack this one um still health
but drained Eve we need the opposite it's cigarettes that
are the opposite cigarettes oh gosh Eve is hard to come by
okay I use so much of it
The circus of values!
What is the greatest lie ever?
What is the most vicious obscenity ever perpetrated on
mankind?
You think Big Dottie's still in there?
Oh, I hear her talking.
Angel, she said.
Goodness, you're so cute!
What do you mean?
Lily Poppy!
And living there is the Lily Poppy!
Thank you, Mr. Bee.
Time for Betty Pie, Mr. Bee.
Mr. Bee is so cute.
Betty Pie.
Alright.
Wait.
Let's save real quick.
I'm saving coming again.
Mr.
Bubbles.
So you're gonna throw more of them?
Oh, dang it.
I can't, I don't think I can get him though.
Can I?
Maybe I can.
Ah!
Oh, oh!
Arto, oh.
That's fine probably.
Oh, hi!
Dang it.
Don't think.
Oh, I didn't have...
attack this one though.
Oh, this one's hard!
Minky the bomber.
If only I had better aim.
Save scum?
Well, I could retry, that's true.
Symmetry.
I don't know what he just did, but...
Was he throwing grenade at me?
Oh, shit!
How the- Oh, shoot!
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
That wasn't good.
I guess I could have, uh, used my...
Hand on it, but whatever.
Oops.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh my god, she's alive!
She returned!
Oh.
Another haunted rag doll.
It's so funny.
I have a question.
Um, if my health gets so low, little sisters in this level
too.
That's so scary.
I do like games that don't really hold your hand so much,
but also I want hand holding.
Me too!
Um, you can loot the robot.
You're so right.
Where did it die?
I don't remember.
Oh, it exploded over there.
Um, okay, so I have nine health packs, right?
If I lose all my health, does it automatically use the next
health pack, or am I dead?
That was my question.
No, you're dead.
Okay, good to know.
I have, I've been, I've been drinking this like Yuzu honey
tea.
But all the left, like the Yuzu peels, uh, yeah, let's say
real quick, you're right.
All the Yuzu, um, settles at the bottom.
And so I just like, got a mouthful of Yuzu.
Oops, I missed.
Is there a...
Is there...
I don't think I can hide...
Ouch!
Hmm.
Intense user flavor.
Yeah, but it's really good.
Okay.
Yeah, I think I just gotta, like, rush it.
I think I...
Go.
Uh-oh.
It's pretty difficult.
What is this?
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Uh...
Okay, nice, nice.
It
speeds up the flow.
It sounds the alarm if you finish pointing at it.
Oh, that's no good.
Okay, actually, I took way less damage than I thought I
would.
So that's not All bad?
Static.
Charge.
You emit a burst of electricity when struck damaging all
around you!
Okay.
Sure.
It summons bots.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
Good to know.
Thank you, guys.
Guys are so helpful.
It's so nice.
Thank you.
No ice.
Alright, sorry.
I'm going to save again.
Save.
I'm just going to save over the last thing I did.
Yippee!
Okay.
Got my...
I'm just looking around real quick.
It looks like it wants me to go in there, potentially.
you see the guy like in the in the corner you see him but
before we do that
what the how did it see me I don't even see it
what is yeah I want to hack it
Maybe if I run...
Hack!
Oh, I got it!
Oh my gosh.
I'm shocked.
Uh...
Sure.
Where's the...
Oh, down there.
Okay.
Oh,
we might be able to get this.
Oh, sh...
Uh, oh, uh...
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Uh.
And then this.
Yeah, I think that's it.
Yay!
Oh, another safe.
Look at that crab!
Well, there's so good a lot of supplies and stuff.
Kind of awesome.
Okay.
Ah!
Wait, we're gonna save scum this.
That's what you notice, of course I noticed the crab.
Oh my god, it's one of these again.
Okay, uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh no, no!
Uh, you.
And then, uh, you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, and then, uh, you.
And then you.
Uh, you?
You.
First try.
Medrito, somewhere beyond the sea.
What is your wisdom of the day?
Saving or dooming the sisters?
Is that what you said?
I'm a little sister believer.
That was close, wasn't it?
That was pretty dang close.
Okay There's two first aid kits in there
Try and remember that save the sisters save the sisters
Somewhere Beyond the sea.
Oh dang it.
I just realized the bandages Someone waiting for me
Aphrodite.
I have what you're looking for.
Just open your eyes.
And she cuts me into a thousand beautiful pieces.
I already think we're gonna have to fight this thing, aren't
we?
Whatever the heck it is.
Lobster!
Oh.
That's not so good.
For that guy.
Oh, geez.
They're like so messed up looking.
Steinman's officially lost it this part I'm scared I'm not
gonna lie I keep saves coming because I'm scared hold on I'm
gonna save like right we're gonna save right in front of the
door I'm so scared I'm just scared
there he is you can see him
from here he looks like Volgan actually guys eye on him i
have to go to the little ghosty's room is that okay sorry i
have to go to the little ghosty's room okay you just keep it
make sure he doesn't move from there all right just let him
just um i'll be fast just uh just keep an eye keep watch
okay if we die a good thing i just saved right okay i'll be
right back
did he do anything cool did he start juggling body parts.
Did he learn a new dance?
Oh, he hit the gritty?
He did a flip!
Oh, my God.
I was watching being smug.
What smug?
What's that?
I wonder if we'll want this.
Wait, Adam.
Denies us any excuse for not being beautiful.
And then, um...
Maybe our shoddy.
I know I just saved, but...
Because I'm here.
All right.
Well, let's see how the fight goes first.
Oh.
There's so many storage things.
Search containers for loot.
I tried.
There's nothing.
Thanks for telling me.
Thanks for helping out.
I really appreciate it.
Gosh.
Search for loot.
That doesn't exist.
Okay.
Front seating.
Try freeze on hackable stuff to slow it down.
Wait, I'm- wait.
Thank you for helping.
Unity child, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Yeah, by the way, search containers for loot.
By the way, they probably won't have any.
Alright, I'm ready.
What can I do with this one, Aphrodite?
I want to make them beautiful, but they always turn out
wrong.
That was too fat.
This one too tall.
This one too symmetrical.
I thought you...
What's this, goddess?
An intruder.
He is ugly.
Ugly.
Hey, that's not very nice.
Look at you.
It is.
Oh, oh, with your Gs.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
You know who I am?
I wish I didn't.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Ah, geez!
I think I'm just gonna keep shooting you.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
It just won't stop.
It just won't stop!
Oh my god, this guy can eat the million bullets!
Where is he?
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
Get the key from Steinman.
Okay.
Thanks Atlas.
No, Eve.
This game is cruel.
you're not ugly by the way he just has really high not what
she wanted oh
the nose looks terrific dr steinman doctor you know I didn't
realize how much her face sag scalpel excuse me scalpel uh
doctor she's not booked for a facelift let's just come in
here oh my god doctor stop hurry
get me the chief of surgery now
freaky all right let's switch to let's switch to my trusty
wrench i'm i'm looking for any anything i was trying to blow
those up
i wish i could search these Everything is empty.
Oh, heal station.
Okay.
I saw the safe.
Don't worry.
Wait, what was that?
Okay, let's hack the safe.
Save.
Oh.
Holy cow.
That guy was so tanky.
we need fire to blow them up really wait can i use my wrench
on them dang well to be honest i wouldn't be able to do
anything right now so
oh shoot oh my gosh wait
oh easy moist suit
thanks why is eve so hard not even cigarettes or nothing i
guess honestly your best bet is to spend money on eve and
then just find heals when you can eve okay
because everyone uses eve for everything and so do i I don't
care about everybody else.
It seems like these are why I put ammo in random drawers of
my house and in random drawers of other houses and places
too.
How considerate of you.
How considerate.
Alright.
We save.
We'll save because we did that safe.
Okie dokie.
It's a good thing I had my shotgun, man.
Was I playing music before?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh, you're fine.
They were wearing the masks.
I saw it.
Isn't this all this jazz getting you guys in the mood for a
jazz club, huh?
Yeah, just a little fire.
It's fine.
The
savings will happily work out an affordable payment plan for
any major procedure.
Wait, did I hack this?
No.
All right, hold on.
We're gonna save scum it again.
Sorry.
We're save scumming again.
I'm always in the mood for a jazz club.
Okay, let's try.
Oh, shoot.
Please!
Oh, okay, good, good, good.
Wait, what just happened?
No!
Uh, no, no, no.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, there we go.
Yeah, did you guys know that two days, Friday?
This Friday, February 13th of 2026, depending on when you're
watching this VOD, huh?
But as of the live stream in in in two days I will have a
live 3d jazz show that I'm extremely nervous for and tickets
are sold out for in person but there are streaming tickets
available!
I know, Friday the 13th.
So spooky, right?
Welcome to the Circus of Values!
We'll do that.
What was it that I switched this up?
Hold on.
Ah, I like that.
But we probably want to skip um changing those just yet
because yeah all right sorry save because i just uh there we
go okay i really wish vending machines were real would be so
convenient right so handy hello restore vigor and spirit
with the touch of a button
welcome to rapture the world's fastest growing partner
What the...
What the?
These fish.
All right.
Oh, this is open now.
Oh, it does not sound good in there.
Wait, is that Big Daddy?
There's something there.
Is that little sister?
Oh, no.
It's a little one.
Here's your chance to get some Adam.
How?
Mr. Bubba's...
Oh.
It's
you who will be shot next.
Easy now, doctor.
He's just looking for a wee bit of Adam.
Just enough to get by.
I'll not have him hurt my little ones.
It's okay, lad.
That's not a child.
Not anymore, it ain't.
Dr. Tennis Mounds sought to that.
Bitter, do not hurt her.
Have you not hurt?
Aye, that's a pretty sermon coming from the goon who cooked
up them creatures in the first place.
Took fine little girls and turned them into that, didn't
you?
Boyo.
Are you prepared to drain your life?
Oh, she's scared though!
There is another way.
Use this.
Free from their torment.
I will make it to be worth your while.
Somehow.
Wait, how do I use that?
How do I use it though?
Oh baby!
Choose whether to rescue the little sister or harvest her!
If you harvest her you get maximum atom to spend on plasmids
But she will not survive the process if you rescue her you
get less atom but tendon bomb has promised to make it worth
your while.
Oh my god.
Harvester!
Roadrunner cartoons.
I want to save the little sister.
Rescue.
I like how it's like, L.
No!
Thank you.
looks don't make it so you need all the item you can get to
survive you need a boost you got this there you go spend
atom for new powers yeah oh
the garden oh
golden film reels you've unlocked an episode of the
director's commentary oh spoiler warning the commentary
contains in-depth discussion of plot data okay thank you
that's cool you can actually spare the little sisters flesh
with stem versions of the dead cells but their relationship
with the implanted slugs is symbiotic I imagine that eating
them will turn you into one of these crazy guys you know so
you see it's not like
End.
I imagine that maybe there are multiple endings.
And if you spare the little sisters...
I bet I...
What's that say?
Oh, splicer!
I said, ah.
I was like, hold.
Um...
But...
I imagine the game would be kind of kind and allow you one
little sister to eat, right?
I don't know.
Whoa!
Oh, increased maximum health.
Eve upgrade.
Wait, that's kind of huge though.
First aid kids also give you Eve!
Wait, that's huge!
Enrage's target causing it to attack someone other than you.
Is this the one that I need to...
Wait.
We could get the first three.
I think first aid kits giving you Eve is also, like, huge.
Because there's so little Eve around.
You have picked up your first physical tonic.
And then...
We can only pick one.
Okay.
Enrage?
Causes the target to attack someone.
So if there's multiple enemies, they would...
How does it work, though?
Is it, like, automatic?
Part of me wants to get enrage because armored shell is
pretty cheap.
Could be more options later.
I guess that's true.
Oh, it's an active cast.
Oh, I don't think I would... I don't think I would remember.
I think I would be like... I think I would forget about it.
I'll be honest.
you cast.
Yeah, maybe we'll save up then.
If anything, we can always come back to this and get, uh...
And get the, uh...
Wait, please take the pistol round.
Please take the round.
Oh, I can't carry anymore.
Okay.
Am I going the right way?
Actually, now I think about it.
Hold on.
Because we came from here.
Oh, no, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, this is what happened.
It got all...
Okay.
Got it.
Oh, we're back here!
Oh, we went in a big old circle!
I see now.
Um...
Oh, okay, I thought that was someone walking.
We have to go to the, uh...
What did we give?
We got the...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, we just go all the way back to the beginning.
What about the denture?
The dental place.
Dandy dental.
We never got the key for that.
Okay.
And the Ryan asks you a simple question.
You're ready now.
It's time to take out one of them big daddy's.
It won't be easy, but it's the only way to get the little
sisters and the Adam they carry.
Oh.
There is another little sister ahead.
To get the Adam from her, you must deal with her big daddy
first.
I feel ridiculous saying these sentences.
Good luck!
Well, good thing I just saved.
I'm scared!
Look, look, look!
Can I zap them?
Mr.
B.
Mr. B.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
It's an actual real boss fight, so I'm holding nothing back.
Scared me on my knee.
Scared me on my knee!
I'm scared!
These guys are huge!
Oh yeah!
Bioshock failed to properly shut down the last time it was
run.
Would you like to revert the in-game options to default
settings?
They already are default settings.
I'll just say no.
Big Daddy too strong broke the game!
have fun with Bioshock!
I finished my challenge with a Bioshock 2 with melee and
plasmids only, holy cow.
Okay.
Your computer is scared of the boss fight too.
Apparently yeah.
Understandably so.
Load game.
Okay.
We'll just have to do this a little bit again.
I read a lot of reviews on both the original and the
remaster that people said this just happened.
Big daddy, don't fight Fayer.
I'm gonna save right here though, just to...
So we have, I don't know, to have my setup and everything
already.
Wait, what are we fighting at?
What are we shooting at?
It's just a guy there where did you come from so
funny where'd he go did i get him top nine joe
i'm not ready i'm not ready oh
my god
save again you know what yeah let's just save like a new
save
holy cow okay
what if i can i run past him
there she is
Will they see me if I'm like over here?
You know?
Oh.
The way I waddle?
What is this one?
Oh, just kidding.
I thought there was one red at the bottom.
I could hear of, oh my god.
Wait, where'd that guy go?
Okay.
I don't remember where I'm supposed to go, I'll be honest.
Where the hell?
Anyway.
Okay,
okay.
Anyway.
It's better to fight the daddy for the atom.
I agree, but...
I mean...
I could go back and try.
This save has us past him, so...
Was it in here?
Is he still in here?
Wait, they left.
Oh no, I hear him.
Oh, I heard him.
Oh.
I heard him for a second.
I'm safe.
It's going so hard.
I'm sorry.
You can skip the fight, but then you can't save the sister.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
They're so fast?
He wasn't gone for that long!
Oh, I heard him.
Oh!
Also, I just realized if I had my fire, I would be able to
burn this and go in there.
Okay.
I'll have to remember that for the future.
The funeral.
It's too scary.
Oh, hell yeah!
You can actually come back.
Oh, there she is.
I wish I could get them back over here.
You know, like...
Will they aggro on me if they see me?
But I wish I could get them back here so that he can get
distracted by my turret again, you know?
That was a pretty good setup, I feel.
Oh, no, they won't.
They're friendly unless you get too close.
Oh, okay, okay.
You get close to them or attack them.
Okay, okay.
Wow, it's so cool watching him walk around.
Oh my gosh, I missed so much.
Wait, did I miss him?
I thought I saw text.
Oh.
She's just chilling with him.
Anything but fight.
I know, I'm scared, okay, guys?
Alright, last, last, last save.
Last save.
Oh my gosh.
Game, please.
Now my mouse is, like, messing up and clicking outside of
the...
Okay, here we go.
Holy shit!
Oh, geez!
Oh!
I took him down!
I got him!
75 bucks!
All right, come here, little baby.
No, no, no, no.
Holy.
I still feel like, I mean, I know probably things are gonna
get real expensive later, you know.
But at the same time, oh, creepy.
At the same time, I feel like we still...
We get enough.
Where'd she go to?
Another way.
Dream time, Mr. Bubbles.
Oh, there she goes.
Into her little hole.
Into the hidey hole.
Holy cow!
We did it!
Woo!
I'm out of armor, people.
Where are these people coming from?
Oh, remember how I just said my game, my mouse is like
clicking out of my game?
That's literally what just happened.
Here's another big daddy!
Guys, there's two.
There's two of them.
Hey, don't hit me.
Why is there a second one?
Why is there a second one so suddenly?
It did say in the thing that...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, wait.
There's not always a little sister.
Oh, okay.
Got it, got it, got it.
Interesting.
Oh, oops.
I don't feel so great either.
I'm scared.
Wait, I'm fine.
Oh my gosh.
My mouse is really screwing up.
Holy cow.
I was...
Okay.
I was thinking of calling it here.
Anyway?
I think...
Let me actually...
Okay, hold on.
I'll say...
Let's do this.
Let's do the emergency thing, and then I think I'll call it
there.
Yeah,
that's good.
That's good.
Uh-huh.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
Upwards.
And overwards.
And this way.
I am enjoying it.
I'm having a lot of fun.
Circus of value.
Electric buck.
Electric buckshot is particularly effective against targets
vulnerable to electricity.
Whoa.
Okay.
All right.
What is this glowing here?
Oh, access to access to mine.
we have it.
There's nobody in here, is there?
Did I go in here?
Oh, yes, yes, yes, this is this area.
Yes, yes, yes.
The up, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I remember.
Alright, save.
Because if I get ambushed, oh my gosh, my mouse is freaking
out.
Oh my god.
Ever since I had to restart the game, it's been a little
funky.
I'm sorry, guys.
Security alert.
Thank you.
through to port net you now i'm looking forward to shaking
your hand yeah oh we're in the bathesmith neptune's bounty
oh my gosh wait we have what we get to go to different
places your plasmids are losing effectiveness against
tougher enemies find the improved versions of those plasmids
okay new zone uh-huh oh the game just saved On a
submarine, hidden in the foundation of Fontaine Fisheries.
Go to Fontaine Fisheries.
Ah!
What just happened?
You guys saw that too, right?
That was weird.
I think his corpse kicked me or something.
His corpse kicked me.
He was smuggling in religion, which...
Uh...
Alright.
Yay!
Thank you guys for joining me for part one in all these
days.
Thank you for joining me for part one of...
Of...
Of a bio shop!
There are three little sisters in this level.
Good to know.
And we got the two in the last level.
level so there are three that we should be on the lookout
for this level very cool try for this thank you um thanks
for spooking us in the tensetsu cord line of course safe
travels this weekend good luck with the show thank you thank
you thank you this is my uh last stream this week well uh
saturday it won't really be like me talking or anything
a preview of the jazz vod the 3d show vod but like sorry i
won't be like around until i'm back next week after uh after
i i'm so nervous for this show i just want i'm ready for it
to be over i'm excited for it but i'm ready for it to be
over um and uh what else was i gonna say yeah you guys be be
a couple of days but you guys be good and um yeah see you at
the show see you at the show i'm excited for the show i'm so
i can't i can't explain how nervous i am holy cow thanks to
the stream good luck at the jazz concert we'll all be
cheering you on thank you thank you for the pink we're back
thank you see you on friday see you on friday bring it on
this is where the fun we'll continue uh bioshock next week
so have one at the concert i'll be listening from home
you'll do just fine thank you thank you i'm so nervous i'm
so nervous um it's i you know like this is a different
experience for fantastic reality last year i also performed
with a live band but it was just a couple of songs this is
like a whole show you know so it's been a lot more pressure
and it's it's it's all it's basically all me so it's so much
pressure dargo thank you it's goofy how big daddy broke the
game but he was so big it couldn't be helped i can't believe
that happened either that was so funny um so i'm excited to
be sing-mogged at your jazz maxing concert don't let your
cortisol spike too hard twin We are not twinning.
We believe in your power will be awesome.
You got this, Vito.
I can't wait to watch it.
Thank you.
Will you be by Valentine?
Oh, I think I've got plans that day.
Can't wait for the show.
See you in LA soon, Vito.
Thank you.
My plans will involve sleeping after staying up until...
What's crazy, even as the show goes until like 1 a.m.
ish the second show goes until 1 a.m.
ish for me which is like 4 a.m EST so luckily that one is
not being streamed because I might just be hallucinating by
that point
I might be hallucinating but I'll do my best don't fall
asleep mid show I know I'm nervous you're gonna be amazing
thank you brick thank you I'm so nervous but thank you guys
for this stream before me for before I head off and I'll see
you guys in a couple of days oh wait wait I just remembered
tomorrow I'm gonna try and do a watch along of the state of
play wait I just realized VOD watchers I guess we'll see if
that happens or not but maybe I'll see you tomorrow then
maybe I'm gonna try I see how the first of all hopefully
like I don't get delayed or anything and second of all if I
have proper Wi-Fi thank you for the peak you'll be amazing
I'll be cheering you on for mom thank you now well thank you
so much for the peak good luck on the concert we'll be
cheering for you on 1 a.m.
so also happy early Valentine thank you if if i can't do a
stream stream i could do a twitter space we could try that
instead so yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll we will watch the state
of play together somehow some way thank you everybody
otubito i will see you when i see you next hopefully
tomorrow
Thanks for helping me today with so much stuff explaining
about the game.
I really appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
I've got a good thing we only had one crash.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, good, good, good job, everybody.
What's up, it's all?
Bye-bye.
Have a good weekend.
Nina, are you still here?
I just saw that aren't you dead?
That's so stinking cute.
It's so cute!
I just saw...
Thank you!
Crash Doki's Watch Along if you can't do your stream.
Oh, I'll ask her if I can't do my own.
Thanks!
Tara wants to be Big Papa.
I say, Denied, denied, denied.